lady when I tell you you did Ursula down
[Music]
how much whiskey and
um I well things that you shouldn't
smoke down there but I just thought
she's such a broad but she's also a
stunted person and she's damaged and
she's been alone a long time which I
found very interesting to play after
we'd all been in isolation for two years
her mental health was an issue and just
how much has she been talking to herself
by the time I really started to put her
together
is a real 3D
per character I fell so in love with her
I felt such empathy for her I also knew
she does lots of bad things but she
became so complicated that I really kind
of fell for her and it just kind of
seemed like everything was like weighted
with her like she you know her movements
were weighted her voice I don't know why
it just it kept getting deeper I was
like I mean really by the end I was like
I must be eating gravel at night I don't
know we got a deal no King Triton is the
ultimate helicopter parent it seems
you're a parent you guys are both
parents how do you compare him are you
strict
I'm far from I hope I'm far from that
but maybe my kids will say the opposite
but uh but I can relate to the pain and
fear that can cause when you see that
your daughter is becoming
uh an independent person that wants to
go off the nest uh that is not happening
still but it will happen and I guess it
will be it will be a process that I have
to go through and I understood that from
him what about for you Melissa a little
a little helicopter-ish
call it helping I don't think anyone
else in my house calls it helping words
so like you want me to cut that for you
and my kids are like no we can cut our
own like and then you know Ben just is
like oh my God
did you guys both share the animated
version of this with your kids of course
it's a classic we'd watched it so many
times growing up it's the movie I've
watched more than any other movie in my
life I've seen it close to 100 times
because I was a nanny and we watched it
every single night for about a year and
a half with the great kids I watch but
uh I think you're seeing it they're like
how are you gonna do that I'm like I
don't know truly I don't know they're
like are you gonna be underwater I'm
like I don't know are you gonna sing I'm
like I don't know but I'm I'm willing to
try but now you know now I know if I had
to make you all pick and I am going to
make you
pick um do you have a favorite song in
the film
um that's toughie yeah your song is
Beautiful
it's amazing it really I think all those
songs are pretty amazing
I mean part of your world because it's
it's very special I mean what she does
with the voice in that song it's it's
very special and just seeing her face
singing that song was so striking didn't
you say you got emotion I got really I
got so proud of her for the the young
woman that she is and that the strength
she played that with but when I'm
telling you it's like I almost get
choked up when she finishes that song I
literally burst out crying I was
clapping I was like my it was breathing
weird and I literally wanted to like
stand up and be like it's not just
because you you are an amazing actress
it's not because your voice is from
another planet it was her it was how she
chose to portray that strong yet
vulnerable woman and I think it's a game
changer and I think kids and and are
gonna look up to her and be like that is
me I can do anything I can choose the
course of my destiny I think she just
played it with such Incredible strength
and vulnerability at the same time that
like she it just was perfect she has
this thing where you cannot take your
eyes off her she has this Aura she has
this beautiful Glimpse all over her that
is you are born with it or you're not
and she she has it and yeah you feel you
feel who Hallie is being around her like
her her it is a it's an experience and
privilege I think to be in her glow
because she leads with kindness she
leads with integrity and I I think
that's we can't shine the light on that
more like we need it
[Music]
thank you